カーテンなんですけど...
間違えて片方しか買ってなくて...
最近ようやく二つ来たので!
このね、やっぽカーテンで…
やっぽとか言っちゃったけどね
こっちがねちょっと白めの背景にすることができました！
グリーンバックちょっとやっぱ気持ち悪いしやめときます
やっぱね白をベースにした方が綺麗なんで
今度からこっちバックで撮ることが増えるかもしれません
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
ちょっとTwitterであることを聞いてしまいました
なんだろな…めんつゆ
めんつゆにスタバのアイスコーヒーを混ぜると
美味しくなる
的な？
感じ？
なのかな？
ちょっとよくわかんないんですけども
おそらく
そういう感じだと思うので今日は
それを実際にやってみようと思います
俺は買ったぞー
めんつゆ
こちらのめんつゆ
（叫び声）
イオンでそうめんを買いました
安田美沙子顔認証されるかな…
美沙子ー！
あれ？美沙子
美沙子顔認証されねえな…
美沙子のおすすめレシピ
あ！これすごい！美沙子の
美沙子のレシピが載ってます！
美沙子頑張ってるな
俺も頑張ってるよ！
…
何の話だ
はい！じゃあ美沙子味のめんつゆと
そうめん
そして今日一人で行ってきましたよスタバ
アイスコーヒーでございます
あっ！ミルクねえぞ！
やばいミルク無い
あ、ご自由にお取りくださいとか言ってた気がするな…
コーヒー飲まないから、その、なんかミルクとか砂糖の加減がわかんないんすよ
ヴぉえブぅ
苦っ！うわ苦ぁ
苦いちょっとコーヒーは苦手なんですけども
このめんつゆにコーヒーを入れてそうめんを食べるとめちゃくちゃ美味しくなるっていう話を聞いたんで
ちょっと今回そっちをやってみこぉぽパーセペートゥぺちぱ！
…
…ッハ
いややるよ
じゃあまずはちょっとそうめんを作っていきます！
湯の中に麺をパラパラ入れて箸で軽くかき混ぜてください
なるほどなるほどOKOK
ああ！え！？待ってどうしよう
お湯捨てれねえんだけど
（叫び声）
めーん！！！
お湯と一緒に麺が出てきた
（やかんを動かす音）
へぇあん
はい！というわけで無事なんとか麺は作れたんですけども
菜箸みたいなのないから
深いんすよ
ああああ！！火傷する！！！
え！？え！？無理無理
深い！
スマホスタンドでも取れないよこんなの
ほら
（叫び声）
ちょびっと取れた
（スマホスタンドを置く音）
やっぱ箸で取るしかねえな
いやこれいゃああ熱い！！
ほっ！ほいやぁ！
OK!
ひぃ
あああっつい！！
待ってなんか手袋とかないっけ…
左手の手袋しかない…
あっこれ手袋
（やかんに触る音）
あ、いけるわ
いや無理だよ…
無理だよこれ…
火傷するよ…！
火傷しそうなやかんの場所だけ押さえて取る作戦…
（叫び声）
待って今日の夜ご飯なんだけど
OK!
（呻き声）
（叫び声）
よし！OK!
だいぶ取れました！もうほぼ全部です
ふざけんなよ…！なんでこんなそうめん大変なのさ…！
あちゃああ！！！
はい！というわけで、なんとかそうめんはできました
めんつゆ、普通にめんつゆをかけたバージョンと
おい！新品だわ
普通にめんつゆをかけたバージョンと
アイスコーヒーを入れたバージョンでちょっと試したいと思います
まあとりあえずはまず普通のバージョンで食べてみよう
ノーマルバージョンいただきます
もう別に実験とかいいからこのまま全部食べたいね
やっぱこれ美味いな
濃くない？でも
これ薄めなくていいのかな
あ！あ！やっぱ水入れなきゃじゃん！
おい！待てそうだよ…1:3
水入れなきゃじゃん！！
馬鹿野郎！
1:3じゃねえか！おい！
水入れなきゃじゃん！！！（エコー）
うん！うめえ
最高に美味しいです
これってことは
どうやって混ぜるかっていうとその
じゃあちょっとそれでやってみよう
まずはめんつゆ1
アイスコーヒー3でやってみます
こんな感じだと
これで実際味くらふぃる…
これで実際に味比べをしてみましょう
これでこっちの方が美味しかったらもうやばいねなんか
そうめんの常識を覆すような結果になるよ
でも俺コーヒー嫌いなんだよね…
見た目的にはあんまり変わらな…グロいなぁ
グローいなぁ…
見た目的にあんまり変化ないと思うんですけども
こっちがアイスコーヒー混ぜたバージョン
こっちがノーマルバージョンです
では早速いただきます
まずノーマル
じゃあアイスコーヒーバージョンいってみます
怖いな
え？
え？これほ？え？待って待っちょおかしくね？
美味しくはないなぁ…
めんつゆの甘味に苦味が足されて、苦くなりました！みたいな
これが大人の味ってやつかね
いや普通の方が遥かに美味しかった
皆さんもぜひやってみてください
多分普通の方が美味しいと思います
じゃあな！